should I just walk away from this I
think apologies videos for suckers it's
kinda like here's the mistakes you need
to make half of you guys probably
watching this video right now on the
toilet we discussed a billion views
across both channels and with that came
a little bit of reflection on some of
the things we've done right and some of
the things we've done wrong we wanted to
share with you guys five mistakes that
we've made eventually learned from and
that has helped us get to where we are
today what's who wants to go first oh
man this is a rant except for faults
working with this actor he had a bad
attitude about everything he felt like
working on a youtube series was below
him that bad attitude just did not wear
off the mistake we made not calling him
out on it
we didn't call them out due to our fear
of completely shutting down our set what
is the worst that could have happened we
still have a guy with the bad attitude
onset right he still gives us mediocre
performances yeah so how did you learn
from that what are you gonna do next
time I guess we're gonna have to just be
be frank you have to call them out that
peer pressure is a good thing especially
when they know there are no environment
where people are counting on them you
have to risk angering people every once
in a while to keep everyone happy number
two I'll go when you're working with
clients and you're delivering a product
or service to another person there's
always gonna be a moment where you need
to say should I just walk away from this
and if you can't if you don't allow
yourself that out it's gonna be a long
hard road few years ago we did a series
the division the the road to getting
there it should have been a lot easier
is because we didn't put ourselves in a
position to be able to walk away the
terms of the deal we would get paid upon
final delivery we spent a lot of money
we couldn't walk away from it after that
point we were stuck they knew that in a
way they pushed us and pushed us and
pushed us so recent an example where we
learned from where we learned from that
is mego is going to tell you about it
right here yeah I remember last year we
built a it costume from destiny we
started the production we started the
brand integration sorry
we were having trouble getting a concept
out or that we were comfortable with
shooting that bungee also liked we
actually pitched 11 concepts all of them
got turned down because one reason or no
it was a very sensitive time for destiny
that was an agenda the corporation is
the person makes the decision on their
end is insulated between you and them by
about ten more people and so you don't
have any chance of compromise they're
gonna say it even offhand and you will
have to do it and that's gonna go on
forever until that person's done being
nitpicky with stuff it's why here at
Porter digital we only have an
insulation of two people between the
decision and the end product probably
notice that a destiny video never came
out and that's because we walked away
from the project one mistake you don't
need to make is missing out on our
incredible special Black Friday
merchandise sales it's going on now for
example we have this portal trickshots
inspired a comic T is super comfortable
it's super fun and even though Ren
directed the video I liked it so much
that I said hey Ren let me do this
safety buddy anyway it's available at
corridor digital docks store another
mistake we've made be clear upfront with
what you're going to do and stick to it
don't compromise because once you
compromise it the other person just ask
for more and more and more and more as
long as they're asking for it from you
and you're going to do it it's a one way
compromise all you'll do this you do
this - Peters - I'm just saying you need
some of that to succeed I don't like
saying something I know it's gonna have
a negative reaction so if they asked me
if I can do this one thing
I know they're gonna be upset when I say
no but we really should be doing it
sometimes it's a bit of an internal
struggle and sometimes I've said yes
last week yes I meant to do that last
week this takes us actually back to the
division but we had agreed to do for the
project was for YouTube videos what
ended up becoming the goal at the end of
the project was not for YouTube videos
until they still happened there's a
full-on 40 minute long Amazon special on
Amazon Prime now the delivery for
something like that is very different
than YouTube video once everything was
done they come back and say you need to
remove every single logo from the piece
this was never something set up
beforehand when we bought the project on
this is never something that we needed
to deliver from her YouTube from that
experience we have learned to be very
explicit and very clear upfront with
what we're delivering and if people push
back on us doing the process we say no
that doesn't mean it doesn't happen it
means that if we can do it we can then
do it and surprise them and make them
kappa thank you is a pretty big mistake
the difference between leave yourself
the ability to walk away and the other
is be clear with your expectations up
front and don't compromise for the sake
of yeah you see online all the time
somebody makes an apology video I
already explains about the apology video
isn't good enough but every would rather
be making an apology video the no
apology video apology videos for suckers
90% of them are just monetized anyways
Lazer's has been interesting I've spent
the majority of my time actually camera
tracking everything
this is when the biggest issues about
iPhone footage comes out blaringly
obvious it takes pretty decent video if
you're holding the camera still if I if
I want to record a video right and I
started doing stuff like oh yeah this is
cool but then motion blur gets out of
control so just before we actually
rolled on this shot I took a piece of
gaff tape I put it on the shelf over
there and I circled in with silver
sharpie a nice big circle that gave me a
nice point to track in post but look at
this point but once the camera starts
moving look at what happens to that dot
no it's still there it's just now a line
so this right here should be a dot so
classically when you're shooting
something each frame is exposed for a
certain amount of time so that means if
you're 30 frames per second a 360 degree
shutter would be 1 over 30 a thirtieth
of a second one for every frame right I
think it has like a variable shutter
speed so that it'll actually lower the
shutter speed if there's not enough
light so that the shutter stays open
longer to get more light the downside is
that when you move because that shutter
is open it's recording everything as it
motions around that's called motion blur
I go a hundred and eighty miles an hour
at all times
the idea behind camera tracking and
match moving is that it tracks dozens or
hundreds of points throughout your scene
and then it basically just throws a lot
of math at it and recreating the actual
camera movement not just rotation wise
but through 3d space how are able to
create CG objects and place them into
the scene as if they're actually there
Matt's moving program doesn't know how
to track this anymore because it's like
looking for a very specific type of
image and that image no longer exists
because it's been stretched to oblivion
with us in our brains and our smart
interpretation of context we know that
that point is now aligned and so I can
take a manual tracking point and place
it on that dot throughout the shots held
the program how the camera is moving so
each of these little red die
is a specifically placed keyframe that's
why this becomes a little tedious
because it can't automatically solve the
shot I have a feeling that the iPhone
recorded at a lower shutter speed than
the frame rate and that causes these
crazy stretched motion blur lines oh hey
how's it going just thinking about the
past anyway did you think I was here to
sell you this shirt again because I'm
not I'm here to sell you this hat it's
actually really comfortable we put a
little quarter did it'll tag on it it's
perfect for everyone who's going through
the winter and you're not here in LA
with us in fact this hat is so
comfortable that when we received the
samples for it Carmichael went out found
the manufacturer and bought his own hat
the same hat in a different color
because he liked it so much he's wearing
it right now turn the camera around turn
the camera around I think that's all I
need to say that we might want to
restructure these mistakes so that way
they all compound like this they do kind
of tell a linear story in a way I had it
I had them linearly planned out but we
kind of just went it's not over promise
under deliver its under-promise
over-deliver we established for a while
that we would do really expensive
looking stuff for cheap the reason is
because we would make very little money
on it and we just spend it all in the
production and stretch of selsun and
pull all nighters did that became the
expectation for all projects that were
offered to us after that so it became
old why can't you do it for this why
can't you do it for that now we say
here's what we can deliver on and it's
like you said under promise that way
when we work on and then throughout the
course of working on it we leave
ourselves some room you know it's not
like well sorry hon I got to work the
next eight weeks every weekend you don't
want to live like that no one should
live like that it's not to say you don't
push yourself I think really the
counterpoint to some of this stuff is
we're calling them mistakes but in a way
they're also kind of a rite of passage I
mean we
when we moved to LA we were doing VFX
shots for 50 bucks each he comes back
this the client he's like alright hey
can we do another more for 50 each I'm
like I want $100 per shot he's like whoa
I thought you did him for 50 I'm like
well yeah but that's you know I think
that was last one for while Ren's
figuring out tracking iPhone footage
which is the worst by the way I am
getting a look for the laser and I'm
talking with Nikko I'm pulling ecocide
when he's like got two seconds he's no
use you know the bathroom nope that's
kind of like being in a NASCAR driving
around the track and then every time you
cross that checkpoint you just feel like
a thumbs up and you're like I'll adjust
something but then sometimes you got to
come in for that pit stop you know when
you pull in tires are all burnt out and
you're like man let's have a little
combo here usually that's when Nikko is
trying to use the restroom but I'm like
hold that poo because we need to talk
right now
always when he's using the restroom
though that's the key that's the key
half of you guys probably watching this
video right now in the toilet but let's
say someone just banged on your dorms
like yo yo I need notes now on a video
and you have to like this and you have
to give those notes keeps you alert it
keeps you it keeps going
that's like knee goes experience but he
never made it to the bathroom that's
yeah this is a pretty straightforward
video I love doing effects I love doing
effects cuz cuz honestly I'm at the
point now where I can comfortably do
effect there's not really many question
marks anymore they're not talking at all
you know Ren is so good at visual
effects and I consider myself very good
official effects as well so the two of
us combined it's just like unstoppable I
feel and we're just bouncing back and
forth so well and we fill in each
other's gaps so well it's such a great
experience
I mean downsides I mean there aren't
really downsize another mistake you
don't have to make is missing out on
this incredible low-poly floral custom
cut
Oxford tea or better known as a Hawaiian
shirt the quarter Digital Hawaiian shirt
something we designed completely from
scratch tender Thomas designed this
incredible pattern had the fabric
printed the fabric turned and cut and
sewn into these shirts these are these
are incredibly unique for one-of-a-kind
need a snag one right now because this
is this is something we've been working
on for months and I'm so excited that it
is finally released
one last special as part of this whole
Black Friday fake orders of sixty or
more are going to get a free pin with a
pin backer card that's been personally
hand signed by each member of the crew
orders of 75 or more in the US will get
free shipping so go to court or digital
dot store and also we put this cool low
poly floral design on this long sleeve
corridor digital hawaiian-inspired shirt
look at this sleeve print too someone
once said that these these remind them
of motocross shirts I like dirt bikes
last one that we discussed here is is be
very careful with chasing trends I think
it was mistake did you make here today
there's nothing wrong with doing things
that are within a trend but I think I'll
explain the difference after this here
we thought hey you know it's a trend
that's happening right now that's super
successful on YouTube kids channels the
problem is they're all garbage all
guards are all horrible for children we
feel like we should contribute to this
in a positive way we had the best
intentions and we created an animated
kids channel called cranium kits it's
still up it's still alive and we this is
the first time I think we've ever even
brought it up we actually promised we
had never promoted from yeah this isn't
a promotion the intention was it had
these characters that had counting
wizard who would count a bunch of things
that had alphabet e who would do stuff
by alphabet Gabe and Gabe and Jarrett
were working on it almost every day it
was really cool we were really excited
about it but it didn't work and the
reason why it didn't work is because we
relate to the party the trend setters
who had started the whole thing
we're basically exploiting a unknown
niche on YouTube that YouTube didn't
like and they eventually shut down
YouTube didn't distinguish our channel
from any of the other ones it just said
these are all garbage
and we're gonna sync them all it's okay
to chase certain trends but I think you
really want to be more of a trendsetter
you want to be early to the party and
you want to help set the game and it's
okay if something works and there's a
bit of a recurrence and a trend there
that you follow and do better example of
that and where we learn from it is with
our last primitive technology video I
mean proven technology is one channel
specifically there's like people doing
that style stuff but that was additive
that wasn't derivative that wasn't us
just going out to the woods and doing
another primitive technology video
versus going out the thing like you know
what let's evolve this let's do our owns
dinner own wagon train out this way
directed that piece yeah I mean you guys
sum that up pretty well I don't yeah I
mean well that is the nature of viral
videos in general it's taking something
that every similar with and putting your
own twist on it
rom-coms all understand these emotions
that you go through in life but you tell
your own unique story around it you give
it your own twist we're not saying you
shouldn't ever make a compromise you
shouldn't ever work with bad attitude
but these are mistakes that I think if
we didn't make we wouldn't have gotten
to where we are yeah so we just wanted
to share with you guys and I think it's
getting dark here so think about Dark
Souls and how this is just like we
real-life Dark Souls where you go and
die and then you go back and you're like
I died here and the don't die yeah
subscribing if you are not subscribed to
the corridor crew Channel you might like
it
so exactly the air conditioner again I'm
gonna try to get it down but well I do
so I want to thank a couple very special
people in my life there's a couple very
special people all of you guys that
support us on patreon thank you so much
for helping make this possible what we
do and there's a couple of people I
specifically want to shout out here
first one is Phillip Oxford thank you so
much next one is Nathan MacFarlane thank
you so much after that we have Gary
Dolph
hi Peter od Nicholas Psaltis and we got
G squared we got Taylor Dunbar thank you
all you guys for your support
we also Colin Heaton we have glitch
queue we have James Bailey and we have
Brian and toesik and Toshi and toes
all right this is it moment of truth
there's spikes in the link got hit hard
thank you so much for supporting us on
patreon guys